yeah welcome to this video playing yahoo
door yahoo drawn from the netherlands if
i'm not mistaken yes Kings Indian I
wonder I want a quiet game not if he
goes if I've i'm going to exchange
nothing fancy this is some quite modest
life but you still have some chances to
to press especially if black is not
really knowing the precise way to to
play yeah he knows something about that
obviously 97 rucca vedas am a possible
line ahead does in a tournament game
once so i have some idea what to do in
this tournament game my opponent played
the surprising move night you form check
it's a retreat here if he goes Knight e5
bluntness a piece after up see it yeah
in fact this is this is the way to go he
doesn't really have any big alternative
to look yet anyway so what now this is G
form all 92 c 5 we have many moves i
forgot it got the theory
okay let's let's try that g45 the
possible way to play it's very direct
threatening g5 winning a piece so we
needs to do something concrete against
it yeah this is not exactly the move I
would have thought of but maybe it's not
not so bad
something Luke the AIDS looked much more
natural but ok it's not there's no
immediately refutation on parent ok so i
try to activate him I want to prevent
Bishop c5 ok I can you can go down my
idea is to activate with Bishop age free
this is the whole point of this G 4-h
for maneuver that this Bishop is some is
activated it's my potentially bad piece
no I didn't think about that's not the
bad news probably
hmm yeah cannot hmm nothing nothing
great here let's see five interesting
yes it's not nothing terrible but I'm
not playing for for any any advantage
anymore here maybe I can go each five or
something but this is not really helping
he probably will just take b3 and play
Bishop c5 223 something like that okay
so something else entirely you are maybe
I'm not sure h5 should be 7i this this
can be of course a weakness in my camp
as well
ya don't know what rugby itís okay let's
just take it doesn't that doesn't really
amount to much anyway with the opposite
term khalid bishops the sub position has
some really really draw much
hmm I still wonder maybe it is Jewish
what what can you do um okay
okay look b1 b3 can maybe taking plavix
e8 I'm still thinking about doing
something here because this is a slight
weakness on c4 and yeah frankly speaking
those king's indian guys you need to
test them the endgame once in a while
really get that people who really just
want to meet you and if the Queen's off
they basically have no idea what to do
so in sometimes really happens okay rook
h1 h1 have some slight ideas nothin
nothin to too dangerous admittedly but
can can try
but how to how to trow to try it's
objectively a draw anyway maybe try to
do something on the D file of course
he's got rookie eight but it's not okay
okay let's just just just go back and
now think think again how to how to play
trying to do something here maybe look a
1a for Brooke a 4 B 4 B 7 so the idea
I go look a too yeah probably will play
rugby form yeah but no problem
oh I'm down on 36 39 seconds I never
ever looked at the clock in this game
aha so he's going for a counter-attack
okay I need to go quickly against the
king check check
time warning Luke a 72 f 7
I hope ba this is working
check
check check check check black for Fitz
only time what the heck I even tried to
offer a draw but somehow I couldn't
reach the button and I one with 15
hundredths of a second at the end I I
really don't know what was going on
there yeah of course I overlooked to
look Luke v3 I try to keep the game try
to keep the game going and it overlooked
overlook this one and now i'm struggling
but ok it was just a matter of time here
this is probably ok I'm again somehow
his pieces are tied up but ok we both
had no time at all so it was basically a
matter of luck yeah thanks for watching
this